[Musique]
bonjour bon début d'après midi si
sébastien beauvais en direct de québec
bienvenue à cette émission spéciale du
service de l'information de radio-canada
/ ici télé est ici r d sur la visite
royale au canada du prince de galles le
prince charles et de la duchesse de
cornouailles camilla ils mettront les
pieds voyez les images en direct ils
mettront les pieds au cours des
prochaines minutes à l'aéroport ils
mettront les pieds en sol canadien à
l'aéroport de saint-jean terre-neuve au
cours des prochaines minutes vous voyez
l'escalier l'échelle l'escalier qui est
en train de s'approcher de l'avion du
gouvernement du canada qui a transporté
ce matin le prince et la duchesse et au
cours de la prochaine heure et demie
nous vous présenterons l'accueil
protocolaire des autorités canadiennes
notamment le premier ministre justin
trudeau qui est sur place dans une demi
heure environ le premier ministre et le
prince de galles prendront notamment la
parole pour dire de brèves allocutions
terre neuve et labrador est la première
étape de cette visite canadienne qui va
durer jusqu'à jeudi
après terre-neuve le couple royal ira à
ottawa et à yellowknife dans les
territoires du nord-ouest pour
poursuivre sa tournée voyez des enfants
ce sont les enfants mohammad zia
aïcha et mustapha qui vont remettre sous
peu un bouquet de fleurs à la duchesse
de cornouailles ils regardent même
l'écrivain et font des baux bail vous
voyez les politiques qui sont sur le
tarmac à l'aéroport de saint-jean
terre-neuve faut comprendre qu'il ya
deux accueils ça c'est l'accueil
administratif qui va avoir lieu au cours
des prochaines minutes avec entre autres
des ministres du gouvernement de terre
neuve labrador la lieutenant gouverneur
de terre-neuve-labrador madame faute le
maire de saint john's dany breen et des
deux enfants mohammad zia que vous avez
vu qu'ils vont présenter donc une gerbe
de fleurs à la duchesse de cornouailles
avec le drapeau emblématique du prince
de galles qui flotte à partir du cockpit
de cet avion pour m'accompagner au cours
de toute cette émission spéciale estelle
bouthillier analystes de la monarchie
britannique hms n'aboutit je vous
retrouve avec plaisir bon début d'après
midi a
dit non
dites-nous qu'est ce que le prince
charles et la duchesse de cornouailles
viennent faire au canada
ils viennent par ces trois jours avec
nous pour célébrer le jubilé de platine
de la reine elizabeth donc on sait que l
a fêté ses 70 ans sur le trône de 6
février dernier mais là ils ont
entrepris des voyages dans tous les pays
du commonwealth et
aussi les deux camps budget compte de ce
sex qui se rendent dans les différents
pays du commonwealth pour célébrer avec
les gens de ces pays les 70 ans de règne
de la reine elizabeth qui on le sait
reste en angleterre pour bons lots lagel
à 96 ans et mais on sait aussi que elle
choisit maintenant ses activités pour
pouvoir être le plus possible avec avec
les gens lors des célébrations qui
auront lieu au début du mois et vous
voyez des images en direct de justin
trudeau lui il était à l'édifice de la
confédération qui étaient environ une
quinzaine de minutes de taux de
l'aéroport donc à partir du moment où le
prince de galles la duchesse de
cornouailles mettre les pieds au sol au
pays sont reçus par des dignitaires à
l'aéroport ils montent dans leur convoi
ils franchissent la distance entre
l'aéroport et l'édifice de la
confédération et ils se rendent seront
accueillis dans cet édifice notamment
par le gouverneur général du canada qui
la représentante de la reine au pays
madame simone et le premier ministre
justin trudeau donc deux types d'accueil
l'accueil administratif sur le tarmac
l'accueil officiel à l'édifice de la
confédération parlons de la reine parce
que elle nous a surpris mala bouthillier
la reine ce matin on va vous montrer des
images de la reine elizabeth 2 qui est
descendu dans une bouche de métro ce
matin pour participer à une activité
entourant la
l'inauguration d'une nouvelle ligne de
métro la ligne elisabeth alors est ce
qu'elle est en train la reine elizabeth
ii dissiper
d'autres sur sa santé parce qu'il y
avait certaines inquiétudes évidemment
on est toujours que certaines attitudes
canton à 96 ans mais ce qu'elles
semblent plus en forme qu'elle ne l'a
été récemment
et ça c est la montre et on a vu des
images on la voit marcher avec une canne
mais quand même on la voit marcher d'un
paul certains on voit aussi que c'est
son sourire habituel en fait semaine
dimanche dernier elle a participé à la
clôture du royaume windsor où il a aussi
le spectacle a duré plus d'une heure et
demi et elle était très contente d'y
être très enthousiasmé le sud saluer la
foule alors c'est vraiment je pense
c'est sale et où les tâches
administratives les tâches qui touche le
gouvernement je crois que de plus en
plus elle délègue ses responsabilités là
au prince charles qui éventuellement à
les assumer pleinement et elle elle le
garde plus les activités qui vont à
aller vers plus là la population
britannique
et on le voit là avec les images de ce
matin
qu' elle veut montrer que même si elle a
des problèmes de mobilité elle est quand
même le capable de se déplacer et de
continuer à faire un certain nombre
d'activités il avait été remplacé
notamment pour le discours du trône par
le prince charles s'étaient
c'est très rare qu'elle se passe
remplacé pour le discours du trône mais
ça a été le cas cette année et donc à 96
ans on se pose des questions sur sa
santé mais disons que ces images là sont
rassurantes d'une certaine façon on
avouera même s'acheter un billet sauf
erreur dans un guichet automatique
vous avez vu également à l'écran
l'escalier s'avancer vers l'avion qui
est un airbus 310 du gouvernement du
canada dans lequel se trouve la duchesse
de cornouailles et le prince de galles
le prince charles la porte vient de
s'ouvrir ils vont sous peu des cendres
de cet avion et l'escalier et être
accueilli sur le tarmac par certains
dignitaires de terre neuve et labrador
c'est très protocolaire n'est ce pas mal
abouti et une visite oui du pres de
galles ah ben voilà ok le voilà donc il
faut vite
oui il semble certain qu'ils et après
ils attendaient le moment et mais là bas
on constate qu un bon vin
il faut tenir le choc pour
toujours une situation délicate pour les
chapeaux mais je crois que ils sont
pour la température locale
l'addition porte un manteau qui va
certainement
payé à quai d'opter aux conditions météo
voilà exact les accès c'est toujours
important quand on se rend dans des
rangées dans les régions comme ça on va
le voir aussi lorsqu'il sûrement aliens
onlive
la leur façon de s'habiller va être en
conséquence du climat ou de la journée
la température la journée de la visée
alors sur le tarmac de
l'aéroport de saint john à terre-neuve
ils sont accueillis par le ministre
responsable du développement économique
rural la lieutenante gouverneure de
terre-neuve-labrador djoudi mais faute
le vice premier ministre et ministre des
finances si hoban cody le maire de saint
john's danny green le responsable de
l'aéroport monsieur et rip et voyez
juste là aïcha mohammad zia et mustafa
muhammad isa qui vont remettre une gerbe
de fleurs donc voilà c'est fait la
duchesse de cornouailles et à partir de
là ils vont monter dans un convoi ils
vont se rendre à l'édifice de la
confédération
mal abouti et juste avant d'aller
retrouver héloïse rodriguez qui est à
l'édifice de la confédération un mot sur
le contenu de cette visite parce que on
parle beaucoup du protocole de la forme
d'une visite royale mais sur le contenu
le prince charles se fait un défenseur
des
du climat il lutte contre les
changements climatiques est ce qu'on
peut s'attendre à ce que ce soit un
aspect qui l'abordent lors de sa visite
au saas est certain que il ne manquera
pas de discuter avec les communautés
autochtones danse est aussi un sujet qui
lui tient prêt dakar et du climat des
changements climatiques il va
certainement discuté aussi avec le
premier ministre canadien
et la communauté ukrainienne puis avoir
rencontrer demain à savoir de la
situation qui se vit là bas donc il ya
plusieurs sujets sur le tapis mais c'est
surtout les changements climatiques les
communautés autochtones ces deux thèmes
qui vont revenir très régulièrement dans
cette visite et on peut le voir les
activités qui va faire va l'amener à
aller rencontrer
des groupes au soin au village de sidi
visible voire l'artisanat des
autochtones donc le côté
pour la visite présentement pour sortir
beaucoup on va aller à l'édifice de
confédération on est en train
d'entraîner le god save the queen et où
se trouve héloïse rodriguez notre
collègue héloïse c'est là que aura lieu
l'accueil officiel du prince de galles
et de la duchesse
way s'est passé et je peux vous dire que
on les attend de pied ferme ici
d'ailleurs voyez il y a le premier
ministre justin trudeau qui est là avec
le premier ministre de terre neuve et
labrador vous parliez de l'importance
aussi pour les peuples autochtones il ya
plusieurs chefs autochtones qui sont là
on a entendu effectivement god save the
queen l'hymne nationale canadienne aussi
les militaires qui sont déployés dont je
voudrais qu'on attend vraiment leurs
altesses royales ici d'ailleurs il ya
vraiment des dizaines de personnes qui
sont venues justement certains qui m'ont
dit qu'ils sont vraiment des passionnés
de la monarchie qui viennent à chaque
fois qu'il ya une occasion de voir la
reine ou de voir ses enfants ses petits
enfants donc certains ils sont
passionnés d'autres sont tout simplement
curieux beaucoup d'enfants aussi sont
venus ici donc les altesses royales
pourront marcher à travers entre les
rangs d'enfants d'ailleurs justin
trudeau et elle a un peu plus tôt en
train de serrer des mains beaucoup
d'enfants très heureux de le voir alors
quand même mon sens il ya de l'ambiance
ici là on sent vraiment l'impatience je
vous propose d'écouter quelques
personnes qu'on a rencontré sébastien
c'est toujours bien de voir la famille
royale alors c'est toujours fascinant
non mais je suis je les suis depuis les
années je suis une fan finie
n'avons jamais vu la famille royale
auparavant et comme nous avions congé
aujourd'hui il fait beau
alors on est venu voir
la première portion d'accueil se fera
évidemment ici dehors une fois qu'ils
arrivent de l'art et au corps ensuite
ils vont rentrer à l'intérieur de
l'édifice de la confédération il y aura
des discours des allocutions des
composantes autochtone également à la
cérémonie et par là dessus et donc ils
se rendront aux jardins du coeur dont
quand même l'itinéraire justement à six
plaintes pour aujourd'hui mais on sent
vraiment la curiosité des gens je
voudrais que c'est vraiment l'élément
principal ici beaucoup de gens qui sont
très heureux de voir ce qui se passe là
devant l'édifice de la confédération et
le jardin longueur en hommage aux
enfants des pensionnats autochtones ya
un moment de recueillement d'ailleurs
l'aspect autochtones comme le disait
madame bouthillier combier héloïse va
prendre beaucoup de place dans ce voyage
du prince de galles
petit aspect ludique aussi dit moi il va
s'en aller dans une micro brasse ils
vont aller dans une micro brasserie
ainsi où j'ai cru comprendre que la
recette est particulière
absolument donc en fait c'est de la
bière qui fait avec deux loups de
glacier donc de l'eau de l'iceberg qui
ont plus de 20 mille ans donc c'est
quand même assez particulier
c'est une des premières microbrasserie
ici à terre-neuve-et-labrador et
justement hier on entend des jeux celui
le propriétaire de cette microbrasserie
qui lui a absolument très hâte de
rencontrer leurs altesses royales disait
qu'il ne savait pas encore quel genre de
bière il des il aime mais il a de
découvrir ça donc c'est un petit aspect
ludique pour terminer la journée c'est
vraiment très typique de
terre-neuve-et-labrador aussi le village
d qui dit vie dit c'est un village de
pêcheurs ou d'artisans qui sont là donc
je dois que ça donne vraiment le ton la
t on voit vraiment si quoi
terre-neuve-et-labrador à partir des
différents éléments de cet itinéraire
jours et qui dit wie die semble-t-il
veut dire la terre kaige vue d'un cas du
prince charles se sera peut-être quel
but on verra combien de bière ils
essaient avant de trouver celle qu'il
prime viendrai ou qu'on en voit on
compte sur vous on compte sur vous
héloïse merci beaucoup ont retrouvé un
peu plus tard lors de la visite du
prince de galles et de la duchesse de
cornouailles pour aller à ottawa
retrouver le collègue danielle thibeault
vous avez daniel une petite anecdote sur
les lieux que vont visiter
le couple royal en fait la lide fils
gouvernementales qui se trouve derrière
monsieur trudeau où
une partie en fait la première portion
d'itinéraires va se dérouler il a une
petite particularité vous savez au
canada normalement dans les règles
parlementaires britanniques
les membres du gouvernement sont assis à
la droite du président de la chambre à
terre-neuve-et-labrador le gouvernement
est à ciel à gauche
pourquoi parce que traditionnellement
dans le premier édifice le chauffage est
installé du côté gauche de la chambre
alors le gouvernement avait décidé que
c'était le côté qu'il choisirait quand
on a des filles de déménager dans les
fils qui est derrière rome ac est
derrière monsieur trudeau qu'on voyait à
quelques minutes qui est beaucoup plus
récent évidemment la chambre est
installé depuis 1991 on a maintenu cette
tradition là si vous vous promenez d'un
bout à l'autre du pays et vous allez
voir que dans les riches la thur les
membres du gouvernement sont en général
qui en fait sont en général sont
toujours assis à la droite du
président de la chambre sauf sauf à
terre-neuve et labrador je sais pas si
on va le faire remarquer tout à l'heure
quand je pense une portion dur je
programme qui doit avoir lieu à
l'intérieur vous aurez l'occasion
peut-être de voir ça exane massivement
l'histoire dit elle sur un ami du
chauffage à bois et pts et pour la
petite histoire je peux vous dire qu'il
ya quelques années j'ai eu le plaisir de
visiter 7 7 7 chambres là ce salon là
effectivement il ya du chauffage
maintenant des deux côtés mais on a
maintenu la tradition d'asseoir le
gouvernement du côté gauche nous sommes
rassurés donc pour les parlementaires de
l'opposition
quand même daniel dit mois après
terre-neuve-labrador le couple royal
s'en va à ottawa québec le programme
alors bon visite à ottawa évidemment
rien il ya une série d'éléments qui sont
très très importants monsieur
le couple royal va se pointer ici
d'abord pour pour participer à une
cérémonie d'investiture de l'ordre du
mérite militaire c'est une médaille qui
célèbre son 50e anniversaire cette année
leduc qui sera investi du commandement
de 2 du titre de commandement
extraordinaire de l'ordre du mérite
militaire ensuite passage oublié obligé
devant le monument commémoratif de
guerre du canada pour le débo le dépôt
d'une heure dépôt d'une gerbe ça ça va
se passer normalement dans le courant de
la matinée il y aura une rencontre avec
la communauté ukrainienne à ottawa pour
pour discuter évidemment
de ce que ces gens là vivent depuis le
début du conflit depuis le 24 février
lorsque les lorsque les forces russes
sont envahis l'ukraine ait commencé
perçu de ce côté ci de l'atlantique
il y aura deux visites d'une école
primaire en après midi ou le dieu car
l'occasion de parler d'environnement
avec les enfants qui sont les parents
qui seront légalement et carrousel de la
grc cas flairant une représentation
spéciale
demain en journée c'est toujours
impressionnant 7ème
constation ce spectacle là les chevaux
de la grc avec
avec toute la splendeur et
le côté très solennelle de l'exercice
c'est toujours très intéressant dans ce
sera intéressant de voir comment ça va
se passer demain et puis en soirée
évidemment rencontre après les
rencontres bilatérales monsieur trudeau
aura l'occasion de s'asseoir avec le
prince charles merris 1mn la gouverneure
générale également puis ensuite
réception à rideau hall demain soir en
l'honneur des visiteurs ça c'est la
portion
la portion du programme
lié à la capitale nationale une visite
quand même assez ces courtes en trois
jours en sol canadien pour le couple
c'est la dix neuvième visite du prince
charles la cinquième de camilla et
sophia loren
21 de voyage plus parler d'autres qui
courent voilà daniel merci beaucoup on
va aller dans l'ouest retrouver la
collègue il dit n'être pole parce que
après ottawa le couple royal se rendra à
yellowknife notamment dans les
territoires du nord-ouest quel est le
programme donc dans l'ouest will dean
est pour le prince charles et la
duchesse camilla
ouais sébastien s et dernier arrêt aura
lieu dans les territoires du nord-ouest
vous l'avez mentionné
ça va se dérouler jeudi après midi une
visite donc de quatre heures et demie
avec un programme encore une fois assez
chargé il arrive donc en après-midi
jeudi ils vont être accueilli par des
dignitaires je vous présente cet
itinéraire en trois blocs parce que
d'abord camilla et charles vont se
rendre ensemble à d'état vous le voyez
sur cette carte dans la communauté de la
première nation des dénés ils vont donc
rencontré le chef de la première nation
y aura un accueil officiel par des
membres de la communauté et vont donc
prendre par une série d'activités
culturelles on parle ici entre autres de
prière de sartre de tambours de feu ou
encore d'activités de cuisine et
d'artisanat vraiment ils vont rencontrer
des gens de la communauté l'objectif
c'est de découvrir la culture mais
également les traditions deuxième partie
charles et camilla vont se séparer ils
vont avoir un programme spécifique
commençons par celui de charles parce
qu'il va prendre part à des discussions
avec le chef de la première nation et
autres chefs locaux il va ensuite
célébré avec les rangers canadiens pour
marquer le 75e anniversaire de
l'organisation et finalement il va
marcher sur la route de glace pour
discuter avec des experts locaux sur les
changements climatiques
du côté de camille laddh elle va
rencontrer des élèves d'une école elle
va discuter du programme particulier de
cette école-là et finalement et va
rendre visite un centre pour femmes
victimes de violence
jules galles et domestiques et la fête
va prendre fin ils vont se rejoindre en
début de soirée pour parler à des
producteurs locaux pour parler entre
autres de discussion autour du traité 11
et finalement il y aura célébration du
jubilé alors ici il y aura discours du
prince charles suivi du dévoilement
d'une plaque donc voilà comment ça va se
dérouler je vous parlais d'un agenda
très chargé encore une fois et ce sera
déjà la fin pour le couple princier
quelques mots à quoi doit-on s'attendre
on peut donc s'attendre comme accueil
dans l'ouest
alors sans grand et tout le monde attend
normalement un accueil assez chaleureux
déjà la première ministre des
territoires du nord ouest et du nord
ouest avait dit que l'itinéraire de la
visite sera l'occasion de mettre en
valeur les territoires du nord-ouest est
aussi l avais parlé être convaincu que
l'accueil sera digne de la réputation
mondiale dont jouit l'hospitalité
nordique du côté du chef de la première
nation des dénés s'était dit il avait
dit avoir hâte de cette visite là une
façon de mettre encore une fois en
valeur la culture et les traditions
locales de la première nation oui dit
n'être pas il nous parlait en direct de
vancouver en colombie-britannique merci
beaucoup et bon après midi à vous
au cneser sébastien je vais retrouver
notre
collaboratrice estelle bouthillier pour
analystes qui est analyste de la
monarchie britannique dans la boutique
on parle beaucoup de ce qui tient à
coeur au prêcheur notamment un
changement climatique mais en termes de
réconciliation puis vous avez un peu
abordé la question avec les autochtones
est-ce qu'il peut passer des messages et
ce qu'il peut faire avancer la cause
après tout l'angleterre a quand même un
passé colonialiste
c'est pas toujours été évident certains
reprochent à la monarchie se passé
colonialiste est ce que le prince
charles peu en termes politiques joué un
rôle dans la réconciliation avec les
autochtones ici au canada
va certainement en discuter ils vont
essayer de trouver des façons de
réconcilier tout le monde avec ce sujet
là mais c'est évidemment une question
extrêmement délicate et je crois que
les ça va être plus haut niveau des
discussions que des maîtres vraiment là
un communiqué de faire vraiment oui
exactement les déclarations je ne crois
pas qu'il fasse de déclarations très
spécifique sur le sujet mais je suis
convaincu que lors des discussions
autant avec les chefs autochtones
qu'avec le premier ministre avec la
gouvernance générale si des sujets qui
vont être abordés ça c'est certain mais
je serais surprise qu'à une déclaration
qui soit et faites
lors de ce voyage pour
le sujet des autochtones et de tout ce
qu'ils ont pu vivre et où autour de
soyaux tellement de différence mais faut
dire aussi que le prince harry va
aborder avec ses les chefs autochtones
tout le côté des changements climatiques
soient aussi c'est un thème qui lui
tient énormément à coeur et là il veut
montrer que ces gens là ont des choses à
nous apprendre à nous enseigner et des
façons de faire pour conserver protéger
les acquis et je crois qu'il se voit un
peu comme un fil conducteur entre les
gens qui sont 4es près de la nature et
les experts et comment ces deux groupes
peuvent
se rejoindre pour trouver des solutions
pour aider à changer parce que
évidemment l'élite s'est passé quelque
chose qui se changent du jour au
lendemain mais au moins sur des
discussions
si on met ensemble des gens qui vivent
près de la nature et qui voit au jour le
jour comment ces changements l'homme
affecte la planète et comment les
experts
modifier leurs façons de faire alors
qu'on lui veut être le le fil comme de
père entre les deux on verra comment ils
profitent de cette occasion lors de son
passage aux pays-bas n'aboutit vous
rester là merci je vais faire un détour
par londres retrouvez notre
collaboratrice mary billon marine nous
avons vu des images et on était un peu
surpris ce matin de la reine dans une
bouche de métro à londres
est ce que les britanniques ont été
rassurés sur l'état de santé de la reine
ce matin
écoutez ce matin et oui ces derniers
jours parce que c'est vrai qu'elle a été
absente pendant plusieurs semaines en
tant que de très rares apparitions
l'avait même manquer le discours du
trône en début semaine prochaine et puis
finalement on l'a vu vendredi à un
spectacle équestre on l'a vu dimanche à
un autre spectacle équestre on l'a vu
donc aujourd'hui par surprise ça n'était
vraiment pas prévu donc à l'inauguration
de la nouvelle ligne de métro de londres
qui s'appelle elisabeth line est
évidemment en l'honneur de elisabeth à
la reine et donc oui ça a rassuré les
britanniques de voir que déjà elle
pouvait elle pouvait sortir et être vu
et puis elle pouvait marcher on l'a vu
sortir de sa voiture tout seul on l'a vu
marcher plutôt bien marché appuyé sur sa
canne mais refusant même le coude tendu
par son par son fils le prince edward
que ce soit ce matin au dimanche et est
là elle allait même pas passé statique
elle a plutôt marcher elle était plutôt
souriante elle a vraiment fait ce
qu'elle faisait d'habitude elle a été
présente comme l était d'habitude et
c'est quelque chose qui est très
rassurant à quelques jours finalement
des célébrations du jubilé alors le nos
téléspectateurs marie voit dans une
petite fenêtre l'arrivée où le début de
l'arrivée du convoi royal à l'édifice de
la compétition interne
jean terre neuve labrador nous allons
attendre que le prince de galles et la
duchesse de cornouailles arrive en
attendant
quelle est la relation des britanniques
en ce moment avec la monarchie il ya eu
des temps durs le prince philippe est
décédé a ri et mégane ont quitté le nid
familial
le prince andrew a été pris dans des
scandales comme en boîte on commet les
britanniques boîte il relation avec la
couronne britannique ans m'ont
écouté avec la reine les relations sont
très très bonnes même les petits
sentiments républicains sont vraiment
complètement noyée dans dans dans la
fiction que les britanniques ont pour la
reine en particulier pour ce qui est la
famille royale en général c'est un peu
compliqué on a vu notamment qu'il ya eu
des voyages de certains membres de la
famille royale en dépit du caraïbes qui
sont plutôt pour mal passé avec des
demandes de réparation pour le
colonialisme pour l'esclavagisme et ça
c'est quelque chose sur lequel la
monarchie n'a pas assez travaillé mais a
reconnu ne pas avoir assez travaillé
donc qu'il y à des tensions de ce côté
là mais quand on parle de la reine qui
elle ne voyage plus déjà depuis des
années et puis dont on sait qu'elle a
quand même tenu le pays pendant 70 ans
ça se passe vraiment très bien alors
tout le monde ne va pas aller pavoiser
dans les rues pour célébrer les soixante
dix ans de règne d'elizabeth 2 du 2 au 5
juin mais il ya beaucoup de gens qui
vont profiter de cette fête parce que
déjà il ya deux jours de congé gratuit
finalement pour tous les britanniques et
puis aussi parce que ce soit pour la
reine ou pour autre chose on aime bien
ce genre de fête où on fait des pique
niques gigantesques dans les rues etc et
ça c'est quelque chose que la monarchie
à porte et qui reste toujours très très
chéri par les britanniques mais c'est
vrai que le fait que la reine était
absente et que là elles reviennent et
qu'elle ait l'air assez en forme saas a
créé quelque chose ça crée un sentiment
de bonne volonté chez les britanniques
même ceux qui étaient plutôt
indifférents face à la reine encore une
fois je parle de la reine puisque de la
monarchie en général marie je vais
devoir vous quittez merci beaucoup parce
que le prince et la duchesse viennent
d'arriver sauf erreur juste devant
l'édifice de la confédération à saint
jean terre neuve héloïse parlez-nous de
l'ambiance on a entendu des cris avec
une clameur il ya quelques secondes à
caen
ouais on entendu des exclamations qu'on
a commencé à voir les véhicules au loin
sébastien donc qui ont ils semblaient
qu'ils sont arrivés vous entendez les
gens si une ambiance encore plus excité
je dirais encore plus bruyante parce
qu'on voyait quand on regarde et les
jeunes avec leurs petits drapeaux aux
fondeurs qu'ils attendaient patiemment
depuis quelques heures déjà ça fait un
moment qu'ils sont arrivés certaines qui
sont rares les personnes qui sont
arrivées depuis 10h ce matin est donc
vraiment on sent l'enthousiasmé qui se
ravive de la foule avec cette arrivée
vous l'entendez vous aussi donc le
premier ministre justin trudeau qui est
là pour les accueillir le premier
ministre de terre neuve et labrador et
donc ils vont passer à travers ces
enfants vous pouvez imaginer le bruit
qui va y avoir à ce moment là pour se
rendre à l'édifice de la confédération
tant qu'on sent vraiment cette ambiance
lab qui est vraiment est survoltée on
sent que les gens là m'ont je veux le
voir ce qui se passe ici au but c'est
une espèce de haies d'honneur ne suis
pas si vous êtes capable de bien on voit
le prince charles en ce moment qui serre
les mains des des dignitaires qui
l'accueille vous l'avez dit le premier
ministre justin trudeau la gouverneure
générale du pays merris amman le premier
ministre de terre neuve labrador and
fury et des grands chefs des communautés
autochtones notamment qu'il est en train
de serrer les mets la main en ce moment
donc à partir de là à partir du de
l'accueil officiel parce que si
l'accueil officiel devant l'édifice de
la confédération que se passe-t-il
héloïse il s'en va où le prince charles
ils s'en vont où le prince charles et la
duchesse de cornouailles
alors voilà est-ce que vous les voyez
ils sont enfin arrivés le prince charles
et la duchesse camilla voyez ils sont
avec justin trudeau justement il
progresse lentement peine le temps de
saluer de serrer des mains on les voit
ensemble dans le cinq kilos premier
ministre du canada et le prince charles
qui échange quelques propos faut dire ça
fait quand même un moment que le
prêcheur n'est pas venu ici à
terre-neuve-et-labrador depuis 2009 donc
on sent vraiment cette excitation de la
part des gens on sent aussi vraiment
cette ambiance solonnel les militaires
qui sont là qui attend un peu plus
d'excitation de la part des foules
certaines personnes visées qui était là
depuis 10 heures ce matin donc c'est une
visite importante pour faire une vie
labrador qui était attendu depuis un bon
moment déjà je voudrais qu'on me rendis
à tous une centaine de personnes qui les
attendent les enfants qui sont
particulièrement excité avec cette
arrivée donc on les voit avec leurs
drapeaux on voit les gens avec leur
caméra aussi la cérémonie militaire tu
commences on va écouter un peu et le hic
c'est terrible
[Musique]
je
alors c'est la rue de garde par le
prince charles qui s'arrêtent pour
piquer un brin de jasette avec un des
soldats sur place il y a eu le
déroulement du drapeau emblématique du
prince de galles le prince charles il
devrait y avoir aussi 21 coups de
deux cars viennent de pour souligner
l'arrivée du prince de galles également
quelques performances d'artistes locaux
et des discours qui vont suivre des
discours évidemment qu'on va vous
présenter notamment de la gouverneure
générale madame simone de du premier
ministre justin trudeau et une brève
allocution également du prince de galles
héloïse est ce que bon on voit les gens
qui sont massées derrière vous dans les
marchés ce que le prince est de le le
cortège quitte de dignité un supposé
passer par leur passé derrière vous et
peut-être prendre un petit bain de foule
à votre connaissance
oui donc y est pas encore tout à fait là
sont encore en train de rencontrer le
premier ministre a assisté à la
cérémonie mais vous parliez des coups de
carabine on les entend en ce moment
sébastien donc pour rendre hommage au
prince charles l'arrivée de la duchesse
camilla aussi alors on sent justement
effectivement qu'ils vont prendre un
bain de foule qui vont parler aux gens
les élèves aussi qui les attendent avec
impatience mais on sent vraiment
l'enthousiasmé des gens l'admiration
aussi demande ce qui se passe on sentait
beaucoup de curiosité ce matin par
rapport à cette arrivée et bien ça se
passe en ce moment donc il y à cette
cérémonie militaire ça faisait longtemps
qu'on n'avait pas vu un événement comme
ça ici devant l'édifice de la
confédération forcément ça pesait depuis
2009 que la famille royale d inculpation
n'était pas venu ici avec la pandémie ou
s'il ya eu moins et d'événements comme
ça au cours des dernières années donc
beaucoup de gens qui voulaient voir ce
qui se passait aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'enfants ou sinon vraiment des gens de
tout âge qui veulent rencontrer la
famille royale voir si c'est la même
chose dans la vraie vie que quand on les
voit à la télé certaines personnes mans
ça donc ça c'est à voir mais oui en une
foule un peu plus tard plusieurs
personnes qui étaient contentes même
juste de rencontrer simplement le
premier ministre justin trudeau où
beaucoup d'enfants qui étaient très
excités donc c'est quand même un
événement là de grandes pompes ici à
terre-neuve en ce moment c'est vrai que
ce sont des gens qu'on voit d'habitude à
la télé et qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de
voir dans sa cour et donc je présume que
pour les gens de terre-neuve et labrador
c'est en effet un événement important je
vais peut-être
ramener madame beauty pour parler de
cette cérémonie protocolaire qui
accompagne chaque visite royale n'est ce
pas c'est très formaté quelle est
l'importance de ceux du protocole au
tour des membres de la famille royale
il reste qu on sait que les forces
armées le prince charles au fait pendant
sa jeunesse était un militaire il a même
été commandant d'une frégate
donc dans les années 70 donc pour la
famille royale tout ce qui est le côté
militaire et est très très cher chaque
membre de la famille a été en fait
partie des forces armées soit de l'air
soit de la marine pendant un certain
nombre d'années et c'est toujours
important ça démontre
l'importance des forces armées pour un
pays et on voit que le prêcheur prend le
temps de parler avec un certain nombre
de gens des fois tu sais
à canton il passe la garde en veut plus
et c'est bon il s'arrête à une ou deux
personnes mais là on voit là il prend le
temps de parler à plusieurs d'entre eux
et c'est pour ça qu'en d'armes et là
c'est aussi un honneur d'avoir été
choisi de participer et on va voir tout
au cours de la journée aussi de demain
lorsqu'il va recevoir cette décoration
de leurs deux militaires qui
c'est un conte ignoble il a été il est
membre d'un certain nombre de corps
d'armée ici et président d'honneur et ça
se poursuit mais le il ya toujours dans
cette visite protocolaire une partie
militaire qui s'y ajoutent mais je sais
que le prince charles et membres de la
famille sont toujours très intéressés
d'aller vers aussi le public et de
décharger quelques mots avec eux ou
l'autre des personnes qui ont pris le
temps de se déplacer pour ucp parole
écoutons donc l'hymne national canadien
[Musique]
e
alors la revue de la gare déterminer
l'hymne national canadien terminé quand
yves de queen aussi le prince charles va
retrouver je présume la duchesse camilla
dans quelques secondes c'est une
précision militaire je souligne parce
que en termes de temps ils sont pile
poil dans l'horaire ce qui est
inhabituel pour des événements
politiques écoutons allonge le prince
charles monter les marches de l'édifice
de la confédération et l'accueil qui
dirait
[Musique]
vous apercevez la gouverneure générale
du canada mary simon que partie des
dignitaires qui ont accueilli le prince
charles et la duchesse de cornouailles
mal abouti on
parlait des bains de foule des
événements publics est-ce qu'il est à
l'aise
j'ose vous poser la question est ce qui
est est ce que les membres de la famille
royale le prince charles en particulier
sont à l'aise dans ce genre
d'événement de bonnes foules
depuis le temps qu'on en fait oui
peut-être que aussi dans les années 70
c'était plus du ciel mais leur
maintenant on sent très très bien qu'ils
sont contents de pouvoir parler avec les
gens et les jeunes et c'est c'est
toujours un plaisir pour chacun des
membres de pouvoir échanger et et on
voit les gens aussi
est enthousiasme d'échanger avec u2 tu
certain que
yahia peau on voit les gens avec leurs
leur caméra qui prennent des
photographies donc ça fait partie
maintenant de chaque rencontre toujours
ses besoins senti le besoin de le faire
c'est à dire que on avait on a eu
l'impression d'entendre la monarchie
était dans un autre monde très loin de
la population du peuple est-ce que ça a
évolué au fil des ans ce qu'est ce
qu'ils essaient de se montrer plus
proche de la population
cette pratique de faire des bains de
foule a commencé avec le jubilé d'argent
de la reine elizabeth en 77 et 7ème
mouvement spontané elle a été vers le
jeune d'une façon ça et après ça on en
laisse son entourage réalisé que c'était
quelque chose qui pouvait faire qu'ils
pouvaient montrer que cet ami l'a
n'était pas là des gens qui étaient
complètement
à l'extérieur de leurs
des gens presque pas des extraterrestres
mais des gens qui sont complètement
l'extérieur de leur monde donc le fait
que et puissent rencontrer des gens
comme ça c'est sûr que vos débuts ça
s'est fait doucement mais là maintenant
tout le monde aime à le faire tout le
monde aime à pouvoir les rencontrer et
je crois que c'est aussi une façon
qu'il ya plusieurs personnes qui
décident d'aller voir les membres de
familles royales comme ça parce que ils
espèrent d'avoir la chance de pouvoir
leur serrer la main leurs tirs bonjour
et c'est toujours un accueil très
chaleureux de la part des gens jugent
certain que le prince charles c'est une
activité qu'ils aiment faire
on le sent très à l'aise dans ce c ces
rencontres et
il ya toujours eu à chaque visite est
toujours un moment ou un autre que qu'un
événement imprévu qui se produit et il
ont
toujours le mot pour rire pour
dénouer les situations donc non c c'est
important pour hulot de ses rencontres
avec les gens qui s'en vont ils se
disent on voit les visites aimé e
foulées remercie de prendre le temps de
venir du bois donc pour us est important
de rester belle foule là existent et de
pouvoir échanger quelques mots avec eux
ou avec l'eau alors vous avez vu le
couple royal assis à côté de justin
trudeau d'un côté de la gouverneure
générale du canada mary ça amène de
l'autre au cours des prochaines minutes
il y aura de brèves allocutions
notamment de la gouverneure générale
madame simone du premier ministre
trudeau du premier ministre de terre
neuve labrador monsieur furie et du
prince charles dans cet immeuble
l'édifice de la confédération peut-être
juste une dernière saucette à
l'extérieur héloïse est ce que là est ce
qui reste des gens à l'extérieur ce que
les gens sont encore massés sur les
marches de lemon
way les gens sentent encore la ceiba
c'est un peu plus loin dans la foule on
voit certains gens qui commencent à
quitter mais les jeunes sont encore là
ils sont encore excité je vous dirais
j'ai vu beaucoup de gens une fois qu'ils
ont serré la main du prince charles
sauter de joie des enfants de 4e 6e
année poussé des cris donc ça vient
quand même de leur donner une nouvelle
réalité là de voir concrètement dans la
vraie vie le prince charles la duchesse
camilla de rencontrer les autres
dignitaires on a vu aussi le prince se
serrer la main de nombreux militaires
prendre la peine le temps de leur parler
donc quand même plusieurs personnes qui
étaient très contents de pouvoir voir
d'un peu plus près aujourd'hui c'est
dimitar alors on sent vraiment là
maintenant la partie extérieure et
terminer certaines personnes commencent
à quitter mais on voit beaucoup de
sourires beaucoup de gens quand même
qu'ils ont l'air très satisfaits de leur
expérience six mois merci héloïse
pendant qu'à l'intérieur une énigme nous
est en train de s'avancer pour
une bénédiction bénir l'assistance dont
l'assistance pardon pour entreprendre ce
volet de discours qu'on va entendre et
qu'on vous présentait au cours des
prochaines minutes on va les écouter
comment ça se passe et comment c'est
fait cette bénédiction
aucune
jarosch
on tenir un jour aux ossètes au
programme une au mali où tu mises
en chômage au chengdu je trouve génial
ou des auteurs jusque jeudi
soir à genthod ge besoin d'un robin
des bois
l'ontarien jr je rate un dimanche noir
désir ajoute j'ai ma part je vais donner
tout ce que j'ai dit oui et route humide
dès 6h venant du japon est le pays du
joug des souvenirs de warner music
emi et rammstein en haïti pour une
alchimie show made of shadow est jeune
beau défi à noste inapte au houga
toyota oui jma coach m dos d'âne maddow
show durera ce qui est beau et gérard
gohou se contentent camino manito
tchimou
et voilà donc pour cette bénédiction la
cérémonie officielle peut donc commencer
après l'accueil officiel du prince de
galles et de la duchesse de cornouailles
écoutons le maître de ses 20 kg ou
d'autres peinent à sourire si
nous
connaissons que la province de
terre-neuve apador et la terre
ancestrale de nombreuses populations de
peuples autochtones qui ont contribué
à
9000 années d'histoire
abrite diverses populations de peuples
autochtones
nous reconnaissons également avec
respect l'histoire et les cultures
diverses énigmes à daisy nous et des
inuit
j'aime et en l'honneur de vous présenter
une âme est devenu le premier chanteur
et nous plus traditionnel au canada et
qui a servi d'inspiration à plusieurs
autres artistes autochtones et il fut
interprété les chansons des jeans ou que
du labrador
[Musique]
en
à
on
to be
trop
sans laisse
tiens
[Musique]
soit
m
et
[Musique]
whitcomb
t
où
[Musique]
à
quand
bon
tout seul
c'est une
hirano
ou
pas
[Musique]
gr
et
g
c'est
[Musique]
oh
ce pas
[Musique]
je
hop
aïe
au
sonos
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup
j'aimerais maintenant
invité son excellence d'honorables
mairie sahnoun gouverneur général du
canada à prendre la parole
[Applaudissements]
y
avoir un assaut
contre
royal distingués invités
bon après midi
nous accorde tout cas celui qui
reconnut que le labrador et le
territoire de nombreuses peuples
autochtones je reconnais aussi les innu
les inuits et les micmacs et j'aimerais
souhaiter la bienvenue on pressent de
calais la duchesse de cornouailles au
canada dans ma langue maternelle il nous
quitte
à la
priorité mais le
silo inoni amolloise munich nous
narasimha ionique
votre à lequel votre visite au canada va
vous faire visiter différentes localités
et même dans le nord canadien je vous
invite à parler aux autochtones écouter
leurs histoires leurs réalisations et
les solutions présentent à vous reposer
et je vous invite à découvrir la vérité
notre histoire ses bons et ses mauvais
côtés de cette façon nous allons
promouvoir la guérison la compréhension
et le respect et de cette façon nous
allons aussi promouvoir la
réconciliation
je n'ai pas le fait de geste d'un projet
qui n'a pas de date d'échéance c'est un
engagement à vie à découvrir les
communautés autochtones leur réalité
vécue
il est plus important que jamais entrer
en dialogue
en particulier au moment où nous faisons
face à deux du fis mondiaux
comme la pandémie qui se poursuit la
guerre rangnick rennes et les
changements climatiques qui ont un
impact dévastateur sur notre pays et nos
façons de vivre y compris dans
l'arctique
la fonte des glaces accrue fait monter
les eaux
nous voulons
reconnaître nos voix diversifié créé des
espaces sécurité a aussi voix puissent
se faire entendre
aujourd'hui nous vous accueillons canada
et nous vous invitons à découvrir notre
histoire et à la partager autour de vous
souhaitons la bienvenue au canada et non
vos innovateur
lvn better
alors je suis encore en train
d'apprendre
nos histoires et d'aller partager et
partout où vous allez
canadians à élus
canadiens ont hâte de vous rencontrer et
de vous parler de nos espoirs pour
l'avenir
parce que nous avons de grands espoirs
cette visite royale est aussi un jalon
pour souligner le jubilé de platine de
sa majesté la reine depuis 70 ans la
reine a vu évoluer le canada et elle a
découvert notre histoire elle a appelé
le canada sa deuxième patrie et nous y
sommes très reconnaissantes pour son
service elle continue d'être pour nous
une inspiration
et elle nous invite à soutenir nos
collectivités
je voudrais vous enseigner un mot d'une
petite rue princesse anne louis natta
c'est une notion fondamentale pour les
zemmouris qui a difference ans signifie
ne jamais abandonner c'est un engagement
on s'engage à agir quelles que soient
les circonstances
à travers vous voyage au canada j'espère
que vous allez garder cette idée en tête
ce programme en elle parce que lorsque
nous travaillons ensemble lorsque nous
mettons ensemble au travail sans relâche
nous pouvons réaliser beaucoup bienvenue
à 5 janvier bienvenus au canada
thank you merci mais gouache
anachronique
[Applaudissements]
mais qui va accentuer merci votre
console ans
christiane mina hill homecoming
maintenant invité le très honorable
justin trudeau pour ministre du canada à
prendre la parole
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour moi un honneur et un plaisir
de vous recevoir ici dont canadiens ici
à saint jean terre neuve labrador
j'avais que tous les deux vous êtes
venus souvent au canada mais c'est
particulièrement grave de pouvoir
accueillir par litre en forme unitaire
qui jouait près de lucques si
madame la gouverneure générale merci
on envoie trois jours ici alors que vous
allez voyager de la côte est à la
capitale et au nord du pays vous allez
rencontrer les gens de toutes les
couches sociales pour entendre leur
histoire ce sont des personnes qui comme
la famille royale ont consacré leur vie
à servir et à améliorer le monde autour
des
particuliers
cette année c'est l'année du jubilé de
platine de sa majesté la reine elizabeth
ii et le canada célèbre cet anniversaire
aux côtés de tous nos partenaires du
commonweath
la couronne a été un élément fondamental
de notre passé cette année pour la
première fois les canadiens peuvent
célébrer le jubilé de platine de notre
souveraine
et comme le moment de le faire je
remarque pendant les 70 ans de règne de
sa majesté
le canada est arrivé à maturité
l'acte constitutionnel de 1982 notre
charte des droits et libertés qui aura
40 ans cette année qui sont des piliers
de notre démocratie au canada qui ont
été proclamés signé par sa majesté
la stabilité de notre démocratie
et
lié à notre système parlementaire à
notre monarchie constitutionnelle et à
la couronne
certitudes et de perturbations mondial
le canada est très bien servi par nos
institutions
nous sommes très heureux de que vous
soyez des nôtres au cours des trois
prochains jours pour célébrer votre
esprit de service d'unité et de paix
j'ai bien hâte de discuter avec vous
cette semaine des enjeux qui touchent
les gens comme l'importance de la lutte
contre les changements climatiques
un enjeu que vous avez porté au sein de
votre votre engagement depuis bien des
décennies déjà et merci pour ce
leadership
a été un aspect important notre passé
mais je sais que vous êtes aussi
intéressé au travail que nous faisons
ensemble pour construire un meilleur
avenir pour la prochaine génération et
celle qui la suivra non seulement ici au
canada mais partout à travers le monde
au nom du gouvernement de sa majesté
bienvenus au canada
[Applaudissements]
windows
merci monsieur le premier ministre
next musique ok mais notre prochaine
invitée est un musicien neutral par est
reconnu pour son répertoire
impressionnant et son utilisation de la
flûte nord américaine il a utilisé ses
réussites pour promouvoir la musique et
la culture autochtone
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
là
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
un gameplay
oh
guillaume strike merci monsieur pike
next la russie affirme pourtant
maintenant quelques mots de
rabelais au furet premier ministre de
terre neuve labrador
pour tech et mais aussi bon après midi
dans un caisse votre excellence comme
s'amuse le ministre justin trudeau sont
au nord la gouvernance jeudi faute et
les membres de l'assemblée se perd 9
labrador mais celui députés fédéraux je
les ministres distinguer un goûter je
veux vraiment souhaité la bienvenue au
leader de la nation innu de la première
nation unie à carreaux que de la
première nation à la ptac et de conseil
communautaire
il ya un groupe qui n'a pu être présent
aujourd'hui parce qu'ils ont une
célébration d'assermentation mais on
voit une meilleure vie comme probable
avant de fortes relations avec nos
communautés autochtones et nous sommes
heureux que la richesse de leur culture
de traditions soient célébrées
aujourd'hui
dans un véritable esprit de
réconciliation
dans un caisson royal c'est un autre moi
de vous accueillir de nouveau au canada
et en particulier de foire que vous
rappeler que nous sommes la plus jeune
province de du canada mais la plus
vieille amie de la couronne britannique
c'est une journée de célébration nous
sommes en ra vu que cette visite royale
pour souligner le jubilé le platine de
sa majesté la reine elizabeth 2 coïncide
avec cette année 1992 qui est l'année où
nous accueillons des familles et de
nouveaux venus de partout à travers le
monde ici à terre-neuve labrador d'année
dernière nous avons la semaine dernière
j'ai reçu 166 réfugiés l'ukrainien pour
les premiers vols de réfugiés ukrainien
à arriver au canada ici dans notre
province certains autres sont ici
aujourd'hui
nous avons maintenant l'honneur
d'accueillir chaleureusement internet un
mot d'ordre leurs altesses royales pour
partager notre hospitalité nos
traditions culturelles une tradition
autochtone et notre profond de fierté
terre neuve labrador est dynamique nous
avons un héritage diversifier la
sculpture que nous avons reflète trescol
9000 ans de présence autochtone 500 ans
de présence e d'origine européenne et
l'incidence de nombreux immigrants qui
sont venus s'établir ici c'est nous
croient dans ce petit coin du canada le
coeur que nous avons est immense nous
sommes connus partout à travers le monde
pour notre hospitalité notre sens de
l'humour notre sens du travail et notre
humanité
à l'autre de la province nous avons
représenté aussi le cadre et la couronne
à l'étranger sur les champs de bataille
en europe
et votre venue prend un sens particulier
aujourd'hui étant donné ce que nous
avons vécu depuis deux ans mais dans
notre esprit traditionnel nous regardons
vers l'avenir parce que la résilience la
détermination vont faire conflit nos
voiles tous et toujours n'est venu ici
je sais qu'on passe parfois qu'il faut
être de terre-neuve-labrador pour
vraiment comprendre ce qui se passe ici
non je ne crois pas je pense qu'une fois
que vous êtes ici vous comprenez très
bien ce qui se passe il s'agit pas du
temps c'est pas une question de distance
est une question de l'âme de cet endroit
qui vous pénètre qui reste avec vous où
que vous alliez ensuite alors au lieu
d'un accueil je devrais dire merci
d'être de retour ou encore mieux
bienvenue chez vous
[Applaudissements]
5 you premier
ministre
pour nous allons et entendre
de ses abats fils de ron dragon
la bannière de la musique folklorique
traditionnelle de terre neuve et
labrador
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je m'aime
cela
[Musique]
hillion 12
santé
ça
[Musique]
c'est ça
oui je sais
ce
[Musique]
ashton
non
[Musique]
m
je suis
ce
week-end
t
le jeu
[Musique]
oh
échec
[Musique]
ici
notre rendez vous
regardez parfait
je ne sais pas
la santé
[Musique]
à la une c'est
aussi
les chercher
c'est m
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
débordante de vie j'habite maintenant sa
majesté le prince de galles insolence et
pour le canadien et signés ensuite le
livre d'or
à nous adresser la parole monsieur
gouvernement monsieur le premier
ministre
cheikh va vite et cher ami
c'est avec le plus grand respect que mon
épouse et moi-même commençons notre
visite fait taire
ou des peuples autochtones y vivent
depuis des millénaires des premières
nations des métis mais nous
nous ne saurions vous remercier assez
pour la chaleur de votre accueil et la
générosité de vos paroles de bienvenue
je ne peux souligner à quel point nous
avons été touchés d'être invité par le
gouvernement du canada
nous unir à vous pour célébrer le jubilé
de platine de la reine et ses 70 ans de
service comme souveraine
m'a demandé de vous transmettre ses
meilleurs voeux ont cette année spéciale
et d'exprimer la profonde affection
qu'elle éprouve pour le canada et ses
habitants
tout au long de sa vie et depuis sa
toute première visite ici en
ça m'a juste s est profondément attaché
au canada et estime extrêmement heureuse
d'avoir rencontré tant de canadiens et
canadiennes
de tous les coins du pays
je sais que la reine garde un souvenir
particulièrement touchants de la visite
qu'elle a effectuée avec feu mon père le
duc d'edimbourg en
1959 au cours d'une tournée rama câble
de 48 jo la plus longue jamais effectuée
sa majesté avait alors visité toutes les
provinces
et tous les territoires
romaric région à cette occasion la reine
a inauguré la voie maritime du saint
laurent
en présence du premier ministre john
diefenbaker et du président des états
unis
lors d'une visite suivante en
1982 l insigne et la programmation de
l'acte constitutionnel
aux côtés de votre cher monsieur le
premier ministre le pro ministre pierre
trudeau
lors de ce grand événement et à d'autres
occasions la reine est à vos côtés alors
que s'écrivent l histoire du canada
le canada et les canadiennes
occupent une place très spéciale dans ma
vie depuis ma première visite ici il y à
plume d'un demi siècle
j'ai eu l'occasion de visiter toutes les
provinces et tous les territoires
et je garde un souvenir impérissable
des endroits remarquables
que j'ai appris à connaître jeu des
superbes forêts de la
colombie-britannique au littoral
majesteux match joueurs des maritimes
ont passant par la magnificence de
l'arctique
à de nombreuses reprises j'ai vu ce qui
fait la grandeur de ce pays sa
population et les valeurs qu'elle défend
vous incarnez les valeurs mondiales du
canada avec l'âge
il est réconfortant de voir que mes
enfants apprennent à découvrir votre
grand pays comme la reine et feu mon
père l'ont fait et comme mon épouse et
moi l'avons fait à notre tour
alors que nous sortons de la pandémie de
covile 19 et il me semble
particulièrement opportun que le thème
et du jubilé de platine soit de célébrer
les personnes et le service le service
des familles des collectivités et du
pays
si je puis me permettre cela 20 au coeur
de ce qui fait la grandeur du canada est
ce que ma famille et moi admirons depuis
longtemps à propos de votre pays
cela s'exprime dans des
actes de monter tous les jours dans les
petites et les grandes localités des 9 6
ans à l'autre
de la part des travailleuses royaux de
la santé des premiers répondants des
enseignantes et des enseignants d'église
d'or communautaire du personnel des
militaires et des anciens combattants
cela s'est montrée par tous les
canadiens qui ont ouvert leurs foyers
aux personnes qui viennent chercher
refuge des conflits partout à travers le
monde
cela s'exprime aussi par la
détermination du canada à être une force
pour le bien dans notre monde
le jubilé nous célébrons donc les
canadiens et les canadiennes
votre diversité votre générosité et
votre chapeau nst inestimable dont le
monde entier
encore aujourd'hui vous défendez la
liberté et vous vous opposez à la
tyrannie tout comme vous l'avez fait
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale alors
que le canada
jouer un rôle indispensable dans la
libération de l'europe
pour rester à l'avant garde de la lutte
contre les plus grands problèmes de
notre époque
qu'il s'agisse de la vase ion de
l'ukraine par la russie de la famine au
soudan du sud ou de la destruction de la
forêt amazonienne
et de la crise croissante causée par les
changements climatiques
le canada a toujours pris ses
responsabilités comme citoyen du monde
et de la façon la plus remarquable à
plusieurs reprises vous avez montré que
votre pays était un havre de paix pour
les personnes dans le besoin un leader
respectueux sur la scène internationale
une voix indispensable pour défendre
un avenir plus vert et plus durable
et à une époque où les institutions
mondiales de la démocratie semble
fragile un modèle de détermination et
d'humanité
aujourd'hui plus que jamais nous avons
besoin de l'esprit d'initiative de la
compassion et de l'humanité des
canadiens et des canadiennes
baas will look mais lorsque nous
envisageons l'avenir
comme un seul peuple qui partagent une
planète commune nous devons trouver de
nouvelles façons de faire face aux
problèmes difficiles du passé il faut
se réconcilier et nous efforcer de faire
mieux et c'est un processus qui commence
par l' écoute
puis j'ai beaucoup apprécié d'avoir eu
l'occasion de discuter avec la
gouvernance générale le processus
essentiel de la réconciliation dans
votre pays ne s'agit pas bien sûr d'un
acte isolé il s'agit d'un engagement
continu pour la guérison le respect et
la compréhension
je sais que notre visite cette semaine
soviet un moment important alors que
toutes les populations autochtones une
autochtone du canada s'engage à
réfléchir honnêtement et ouvertement au
passé pour forcer de nouvelles relations
pour l'avenir
alors que nous nous engageons sur cette
visite du jubilé qui va nous faire
passer du plus jeune membre de la
confédération
c'est comme une telle vie ancienne du
nord
juste en passant par la capitale du pays
mon épouse et moi voulons vous écouter
et nous informer de l'avenir que vous
vous employez à construire comme si
souvent dans l'histoire de votre pays et
de son peuple les canadiens autres
entrepris une aventure qui demande du
courage
et de la détermination pour mon épouse
et moi c'est un privilège de faire une
partie de cette route avec vous et nous
vous sommes profondément reconnaissante
votre accueil chaleureux que nous allons
vivre pendant tout ce voyage
olala liège
[Applaudissements]
le prince de galles le prince charles
dans un français ma fois impeccable
termine son discours discours dans
lequel il a presque autant utiliser le
français que l'anglais là il va signer
le livre d'honneur à terre-neuve et
labrador en compagnie de sa conjointe la
duchesse camilla duchesse de
cornouailles
ils amorcent les deux un voyage de trois
jours ici au pays qui commence à terre
neuve labrador qui va se poursuivre
demain à ottawa et qui va se terminer
dans les territoires du nord ouest
notamment à yellowknife je pense qu est
l bouthillier toujours avec moi pour
parler un peu de ce à quoi on vient
d'assister
l'appel donc à l'action de la
gouverneure générale mairie semaine pour
interagir avec la communauté autochtone
cette réception qu'en fait le prince
charles en dix ans
il y a il faut parler de réconciliation
guérir dans le respect et la
compréhension vous retenez quoi donc de
ce que vous avez entendu au cours des
dernières minutes mal abouti
c'était à prévoir que la gouverneur
générale était pour parler de
réconciliation et de mettre en place
déjà un mouvement pour que s'accomplisse
et d'autre part on a très bien vu on a
très bien entendu dans le discours du
prince charles qu' il est prêt à écouter
comme il le soulignait il faut d'abord
écouter ce que les gens ont à dire et
ensuite de prendre les moyens il faut
pour justement
passé à cette réconciliation mais pas
dans un mouvement d'une journée d'un
acte mais que ce soit dans un mouvement
lors un continuum et que ça se poursuive
tout le temps
comme vous l'avez fait remarquer il a
aussi parlé
pour le climat c'est un autre de des
sujets qui le préoccupent beaucoup il
veut aussi
rencontrer comme il le dit les
communautés autochtones pour que ceux ci
nous enseigne et à nous donne
l'information nécessaire pour pouvoir
commencer continuer à mettre en place
des moyens pour que la planète plus
continuer à
survivre et qui à part les autochtones
sont les mieux placés pour justement
nous fournir ces renseignements là alors
il a commencé le terminer son discours
justement en soulignant ses ces deux
thèmes là et on sent que ceux des thèmes
qui vont continuer a vraiment appuyé
maintenant et je suis convaincu que
lorsque ça sera son tour de régner c'est
tellement là ces préoccupations là mon
être au bout dans sa liste de deux
priorités mais il a aussi su oui je vous
laisse continuer il a aussi souligné la
le que c'est l'année du jubilé de
platinum de la reine est
et comment la reine
a servi pendant toutes ces années pour
elle c'est vrai le canada c'est sa
deuxième partie elle est venu très
souvent avec une fois comme vous l'avez
souligné le début de la rencontre et
elle est certainement à suisse que le
prince charles et son épouse vont faire
ici le temps qu'ils vont être au canada
pour célébrer avec les canadiens et il a
souligné le voyage de la reine en 1959
avec le prince philippe 48 jo 48 jo il
avait vu que visiter toutes les
provinces et tous les territoires ici le
prince charles et madame bouttier ce
sont des images en direct renvoie alors
qu'il quitte l'édifice de la
confédération va passer trois jours avec
sa conjointe justin dernier mobile nous
reste une minute trente à peu près
l'ordre de succession c'est toujours la
reine évidemment lui souhaite pas de
malheur et c'est toujours chiant qui est
le premier dans l'ordre de succession
est ce qui n'était pas question à un
moment donné que on saute chars pour
tomber à williams
s'est tu sais il ya eu toujours il y
aura toujours des gens qui vont
souhaiter que on saute la reine du
prince charmant mais la succession elle
est bien
en place et à la presle à rennes ça sort
challes qui deviendra roi elle le même
souligné dans son discours la journée du
6 février dernier que elle souhaitait
que en plus que camilla la duchesse de
cornouailles soit couronné aux côtés de
son fils sur ce qu'ils deviendront roide
donc elle a bien spécifié que lors de
successions vaut suivre son cours
naturel
charles et ensuite après lui ce sera son
fils et son petit fils mais là on parle
parce que on est presque rendus dans un
ou un autre dossier ou alors vous dire
je suis je mal à pritchard je vais vous
laisser là dessus le prince jean qui à
73 ans dont qui amorce cette visite au
canada merci beaucoup d'avoir participé
à cette émission spéciale à la fois
suscité ici à 10 soit un bon après-midi
mal abouti merci plaisir thuram est
ajournée donc d'une visite de trois
jours que nous continuerons de suivre
dans un instant bonsoir bonsoir en
progression éléments d'une politique à
tout
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après
vrai
[Musique]